back touring now phoenix but you're not
like backpacking
no i can't right now they're they got me
on a strict uh
lockdown oh because you're shooting a
movie yeah the movie
oh so they don't want me to
they don't want me to socialize with
anybody
have you guys tried wait wait don't you
guys what is his hair
have you guys started shooting uh no we
start shooting i i go into
like lock lockdown two-week quarantine
in one room
uh april 11th i swear to god bro what
are you shooting now l.a
no we're shooting in canada oh [ __ ]
steven spielberg is a [ __ ] bro
he's
he's amazing yeah i'm gonna say i'll put
it out there and so is dan lynn from
rideback
uh films dude these guys are there
there's a reason why these guys are at
the top of their game
it's called just to be around it right
it's just amazing like this guy has
dude you're talking about saving private
ryan and
you know indiana jones and here he is
with joe coy's movie
like full on in that's so [ __ ] like
he's just like
doing narrative half ass you know and
he's not he's not the director
he's just he's the studio but he's he's
he's financing it everything and and
literally he's
he's every step of the way man from
picking the director to pick in the
the actors and all that he's he's the
draft the script
everything he's he's he's right and he's
dialed in
yeah i don't think you get to his level
with you know not doing
being like that yeah like a type like
you know
yeah it's it's amazing like like we just
got a note from him uh
last week and i was just like like
literally when i when i got off the the
zoo meeting i just i was like
is this real like did this man really
make a note
and he needs to see it did you shop it
around or was it just a
steven spielberg um no this is how it
went down dan lynn
dan lynn you know aladdin too with will
smith right yeah that's his and then it
won
it too that's his all the lego movies
those are his
and uh i pitched him easter sunday about
a year and a half ago we couldn't get a
rider attached to it right so easter
sunday is based on my life it all
happens on one day
and uh so that's the the pitch right and
then um but there's funny [ __ ] too as
well
yeah i didn't have malik in the room
[Laughter]
so dan i pitched it to dan dan we were
trying to get a rider attached you know
you know a lot of uh conflicting uh
things where
you know we couldn't get someone
attached to it so anyways
i i shot coming in hot right so when i
shot coming in hot it
aired coming my second netflix special
and when it aired
steven spielberg watched it which is the
craziest thing
right and then we get a phone call like
immediately after he watched it
bring this kid in for a meeting right
when i don't know why he called me kid
um
uh pitched it again you know and he
bought it in the room so
him holly barrio everybody over at uh
amblin man
came on now and then and then one draft
can uh
ken chang uh well came up with the first
just one draft off of
you know the notes and the the things
that we pitched
and the first draft stephen was like
yeah let's shoot it like literally like
no no have you done movies before
i mean i've done like indie stuff but
nothing but nothing else
left this level like i yell man
everything i'm i'm
it's crazy like every every single
detail i'm on it you know what i mean
like it should be at your store yeah
it's like here's the cast like they're
they're showing me everybody's auditions
and
and you know i'm going with the writers
and going over the uh well writer and
going over you know notes with that and
then
me calling out my cameos who i want and
yeah
yeah we're going over i must miss that
call yes
what what's cool about you man is like
you're so
focused but like you mean you like
looking at you and like talking to you
all the time like you're just you have
so much [ __ ] fun
oh thanks you know what i mean like that
that's what i like admire
about you soak it up when you can
because when this movie drops i don't
think he's coming back here
coming back you're not well
unfortunately yeah this is going to be
which one is
i don't even have it
the the joke fan page email i did
you know his cameo his sister didn't
reply back to me
my sister goes who's mali
then he asked if i needed cheesecake can
you tell him yes
man that's funny you you do dope [ __ ]
it's cool to watch
so you'll shoot this movie and then you
go on tour you think
yeah that's what i want to do because
the movie's gonna shoot how long two
months
it's gonna be two months yeah two months
vancouver
vancouver yep yeah jay jay's my director
man
oh i'm so excited um i can never say his
last name
if you want to look it up uh super
troopers you know he's done you know
he's a broken lizard
uh indian you know the indian guy you
know he owned 7-elevens
yeah ever
that's exactly what you said he's right
there in the middle in the chat there he
is
see i can never see his last i got it i
got it that's no [ __ ] doe okay
uh say his name i could never say it i
just call him jay
but that whole cruise genius by the way
broken lizard is amazing they're great
talk about rags riches those guys
they all lived in the same frat house
together they went to college together
they
became a comedy troupe on their own uh
raised their own money
and you know created that that's so
funny oh they're so funny and jay's just
a genius steve lemmy's a genius
all those guys are are amazing so don't
wear your belt like that jay but yeah i
hear you yeah
that's awesome that's like oh five yeah
that's whatever hey let him do it he's
drunk
you know what i mean he's allowed to do
that he's so he's the guy
uh yeah in super troopers where's where
mary starts uh prostituting
like what what the [ __ ] are you doing
he's like hey boys
he's like 40 to for me to touch it seeks
to see me touch it
and he's like 80 for a zj they go what's
the zj goes
if you got ash can't afford it
i like what they get when they're both
uh locked into the uh the back of the
truck remember when they got locked in
they've been there for hours
yeah and then jay opens it up and he
goes it smells like sex in here he's so
funny man have you seen it
yeah it is a classic yeah i feel like at
the time i didn't see part two though
i didn't either i love it love it how
about that
when i get off stage at the lap factory
right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what this front of a bunch of other
comics i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son